There is news that is pushing the virus closer
to Donald Trump himself.
The president has a bunch of what are called
the valets.
They're sort of like personal assistants in
a lot of ways.
And these are some of the closest people to
presidents of the United States.
They're often from the U.S. Navy.
They deal with food, drink.
When Trump is at the residence, when Trump
is traveling, they cater to the needs of the
first family.
In many cases.
These are people that are really close to
the president physically.
And often they are they are close in a relationship
sense as well.
One of Donald Trump's personal valets has
tested positive for Corona virus.
The valet started having symptoms Wednesday
morning, tested positive.
And Donald Trump is notified about this.
We know that the virus can take two to 14
days from infection to symptoms.
It's an average of five days before you show
symptoms.
And presumably this is a valet that has continued
to be in close contact with Donald Trump.
The White House has not said that the valet
was not around Donald Trump.
So based on how this administration works,
we probably can assume that the valet was
around Donald Trump during this time.
The White House continues not to enforce social
distancing for staffers.
Reports are that very few people at the White
House are wearing masks.
Valets are not wearing masks.
The physical distance is not being adhered
to very strictly at the White House.
Now, here's my question for you, and I really
want to think this through.
If Trump but Trump was tested right away when
the valet tested positive, Trump was tested
once again.
If Trump tested positive for Corona virus,
but he didn't immediately need to go to a
hospital, for example, would they admit it?
Would they say that the president has tested
positive?
There's a North Korea like gist to this administration
where I don't know that they would admit that
the great orange leader in this case has tested
positive.
I also.
This is a different story, but I also would
not put it outside the realm of possibility
that Trump and Pence have been prophylactically
receiving antibody transfusions.
The convalescent plasma you're talking about
the president and the vise president, it wouldn't
be crazy.
It's not even like, oh my God, they're Recy.
It would actually just seem almost like that
seems relatively safe and it seems to be effective
at treating or dealing with the virus when
people have it.
It wouldn't be completely out of this world
to think maybe Trump and Pence have been getting
prophylactic transfusions.
But the real story is, has Donald Trump been
exposed?
What are the results of Donald Trump's test?
Has he been taking chloroquine prophylactically
as he advocated for a while might?
My guess is the answer is no.
And right away, when this news was released
about the valet testing, positive rumors started
spreading that Trump went silent on Twitter
yesterday because he had the virus.
I don't think so.
He didn't tweet much for part of the day.
Then he was right back on Twitter tweeting
very, very aggressively.
The most important thing is to follow up about
once again, we talked about it earlier.
Management by optics.
Trump is not wearing a mask because he says
it'll make him look ridiculous.
He may be hurt in his reelection campaign.
If you're seen wearing a mask.
Same thing applies to this.
If it became known that Donald Trump had coronavirus,
would his followers change their minds about
Donald Trump being this big, strong, trustworthy
guy?
I actually think it might be a positive thing
in the sense of I'm not saying I want Trump
to get the virus, but I do believe that some
of the people that follow Trump, who love
Trump, who see him as a demigod.
If they found out that Trump had Corona virus,
they might start wearing masks.
They might start adhering to social distancing
guidelines.
They might actually start taking this more
seriously.
But in terms of would the Trump administration
admit that Trump has the virus if it didn't
require him going to the hospital?
I don't know.
I'm curious to see what you think.
We have a fantastic program for you today.
Remember, you can sign up for the all new
David Pakman show newsletter on our Web site,
David Pakman dot com.
It will soon be morphed into a print digest
version of the David Pakman show coming up
in the next couple of weeks.
It's free.
Sign up at David Pakman dot com.
Also, let me know what you think about this
trumped corona virus testing thing.
Would they admit from has the virus if it
didn't require him to go to the hospital?
Let me know on Twitter.
I am D Packman.
Deepak on Twitter.